attention derrière excusez moi alors on
va vous faire entrer couple par contre
s'il vous plaît je suis parfois
on a eu on a eu des problèmes à la
semaine dernière avec le nom mêlé avec
les vieux le temps les gens tarisio
vas-y et que quand aulas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc c'est un détecteur de
blaireaux le métaux
[Musique]
voyez je voulais diriger sonneries jeux
sonic 4 oh là là là c'est là
que j'avais là j'y fais pas un petit 85
bonnet
enlever le bouton que je
suis quand même été fait exprès mais non
mais non malheureuse
à c'est un balconnet mais oui c'est pour
ça la lune couzeix avait alors ouais
c'est détecteur de gros nichons c'est
pour ça olala la du monde là dessous là
oh là là
on est là au niveau du pubis
et plus léger que l'air que
j'avais une vous avez une prothèse
neurones non voyant pas de montants 10,2
le mois regarder ça sonne malheureuse
vous avez quoi là c'est la ceinture de
chasteté oui c'est ça
vous avez ne pas laisser la clé dans la
voiture j'espère parce que ce soir là
dessus bon d'accord on fait alors une
bonne journée madame de cheveux des
locaux
la personne ne voit quand même nom une
peu comme tout le monde tienne la
mangrove ah ouais c'est là que ça sonne
c'est bon c'est bon on remercie ok vous
y
tenez je vous faire souffler dans le
ballon allez-y
j'ai pris une coupe de champagne avant
de partager sa joie
moi je vais être obligé de vous la
conter la coupe parce que plus les gens
boivent dehors au moins ils boivent à
l'intérieur et moi ça nous fait d'argent
oui
c'est bien
si madame bonne journée
[Musique]